I really think I'd be fine with like
going back to just having a day job I
was a barber for a long time I really
think I'd be fine going back to the
barber shop if I could do it out here
and just do stand up three four spots a
night really yeah it'd be fun yeah I'm
gonna bomb at heart
I got so much battles because of
that really yeah this is a loser and
girls like that in Dallas yeah is that
why you didn't get any
yeah maybe that's my issue I was too
successful yeah explain how the girls
give you for bombing it as you say man I
have friends who like the minute they
got out of jail and they had their ankle
monitors they're on home confinement
they just pose that ankle monitor DMS
are flooded you get more you got an
ankle monitor you're stuck at the house
you'll get more than anybody who can go
flex at the club that makes sense I
think girls want ratchets they want to
know where a guy is you can't see when
you guys